I will finish this conversation about numbers. I am recording it. I will gather the information and I'll set a date that we can kind of collectively group together again whether it's in my office in Woodstock or if you're not from here you can chime in virtually because I think it's a really big conversation to have and if we can do it together and go through our numbers and share that data so you have an idea of where you are and where you need to be.
to be. So stay tuned for that. I appreciate your patience. I appreciate the fact that your staff
are here. I have told all of our teams to make them as comfortable as possible. Encourage them
to tan, to spray tan, and use those wonderful modalities that we've brought in. Our service
department has brought all of those in in Minds 22, so let's make sure they're getting these
right. The first thing, like I said, compliments of New Sunshine. Jess bought this because she's
like these are all my favorite things when I travel and it's something that I
was never by myself so she wanted to make sure that she was getting something
that she appreciates so that you guys appreciated and Charles because he did
such a wonderful job on explaining the element I thought you could pick the
And the cool thing is that there isn't a lot of spots here, so you're doing pretty well.
Just a few.
Exactly.
Four.
One.
Nine.
Five.
Three.
Six.
Do you want to repeat?
Yeah, I'll repeat.
Three drops.
Four.
One.
Nine.
Five.
Three.
Three, six.
Uh-huh.
Redraw.
Next.
If you get clapped, redraw.
All right.
Four, four, one, nine, five, nine, eight.
Woo!
I want you guys to actually stand in the middle of the room and I want you guys to stand in the middle of the room.
Stand up.
Yeah.
Everybody stand up.
Now all the charters are going to be real busy here, okay?
What has she got?
I want you to check under your chairs.
They wouldn't pick her.
Literally everything.
We try to be really specific and deliberate.
Deliberate change something because we do the worst thing that we can do
Collectively right is go back and we say okay. We're gonna change things. We're gonna do it this way now and then three weeks later
That was a bad decision. Let's change back
What and the only give some thought as to how we're going to do something and then what so is that
When I said we're going to make them a little bit blurry, but we'll give you the facts, I wasn't kidding. So I will tell you something I was sharing with Rachel all the way over here. She doesn't even know we're talking. But I was sharing something with Rachel earlier while she's doing that, that I thought I would share with you guys.
and that's this that in we send a lot of surveys out to our teams we have a few
hundred people working between the stores and so we'll send surveys out in
and time and time again the surveys come back with the same thing and it's this
that what your employees for our our influence want more than anything is
recognition we put in over 18 but what's your biggest motive is it money's
commissions, gifts, recognition comes back, time and time making is number one.
And look at the society that we're growing up in. Today, psychologists tell us that this
generation is going to grow up the most non-communicative generation ever, right?
They text everything, they email, they Snapchat, whatever the case is, they're growing up
watching pictures on Instagram. They've lost the communication skills that most of us in this room
So, we spend a lot of time sending cards to our teams, handwritten cards.
And psychologists will tell you, a handwritten note has something like 100 times the power
of a text message or an email.
It's personalized.
It's handwritten.
But here's the kicker.
We never, ever send it to them at the school.
We always mail it to them.
When you get your mail, what do you have in your mail?
junk mail bills negative things right and then you open this card from your
boss or your manager or the office and it just tells you how much we value you how much we appreciate you
I'll tell you a true story this just happened last year one of our managers
our spa directors is what we call them had sent a card to a girl that came to her aid all the
time just never thank you so much came to her aid all the time so she wrote her
note my value you i love you every time i'm in a bind you come to my rescue and
send her this card and this is a girl truly from the outside and we all think
like this girl's going to be the very secret box someday she's dead because
you don't know what you don't know right from the outside we think this girl's
got everything going for them the manager the spa director calls us at
at 2.30 in the morning saw, she's almost uncontrolled.
You can't even understand what she's trying to say.
The young girl that she sent the card to had called her
because she had decided that day
she was going to kill herself.
She had the pills, she had saved them up,
she had no friends, both her parents had died,
and work was the only thing she had
and she didn't even know she was loved or valued there.
It just so happened she opened the mail
and here was a card from her manager saying how much she was loving Doug.
And she called her.
I'm too dumb.
She called her and told her, you saved my life today.
It's heartbreaking on one side, but it goes to show what's missing on the other side.
I would argue all day long that we need anything for our employees.
Recognize them.
Honor them.
Respect them.
Make them feel as though, you know, Doug said something up here.
you know they they have to feel like they're a part of something hey you can pay them all the
money in the world but if they hate their job it's not enough right there was an interesting
article i sent to all of our team it said people leave a job for one of two reasons
money or happiness how many of us remember the the um the series friends and during this hey day
right? Nick, you too, right? And so during Skate Day, they were making a million dollars an episode.
A million dollars? I could hate something a lot for a million dollars an episode, right?
And yet they decided to leave. Why? They said they weren't happy. And likewise, how many of you
have heard about somebody, you know, that loves their job but they can't afford to save it, right?
money or happiness? So, I don't know, I just thought I would offer that because, well, we had time at the time, so, anyway, I know this is what you want to get into, so, there's a lot of analytics here we're going to talk about, I'm going to try and go quick, because I know we're probably going to spend all night here with you by talking numbers, so, and if you do, you've got bigger problems, so we talked a little bit earlier about this particular story,
We were highlighting this one, and Rachel had asked about, Rachel, what month do you
want to know something about?
March.
Went from 84 to 91.
And everybody's like, so we'll look at it.
So this is the revenue per month.
So we track, and here's what I'm going to tell you guys.
Just, this is really simple, and I will even send it to you.
All you have to do is put the numbers in there, and it will calculate everything for
you.
Right?
That's how much this can help you.
It will tell you, number one, and we use color coding because this is all rolled up into a corporate sheet.
So we have 20 of these individually, and then those all roll up into a corporate building.
And what this does is green tells us it lost the month before, blue tells us it didn't beat the year in front of it,
and red tells us that it lost the month before and the year before.
So we're looking for patterns, right?
And so one store by and of itself doesn't tell you a lot.
Maybe it just had a day or a month.
But when you start compiling four, five, six locations,
and you start seeing similarities in those,
you see how that can start telling you things?
What did we do in March that every single location
lost against the year prior?
Well, now we can look at the revenue and say,
okay, when we get down to session count,
where was our session count?
Where was our unique customer?
and then we looked at the data so you'll notice maybe in this one you'll see the
little triangles and so we try to put as much data in each cell as we can for
each store regarding what did we do that month what promotion did we run who was
moved what store manager is there versus you know did we make a change so
anything that we can put in those cells to look back and say okay how did we
possibly lose for last year when every other store gained so if you don't have
have these numbers it's really hard how do you know what you're making farmers
if you don't know what you've done numbers alone aren't going to tell you
the truth and that's why we're going to get to some of these next slides
I'm sorry so this is for one store and so every store will have its own
spreadsheet so this particular store you can see in 2015 I highlighted because in
2015 that's when we made the change we pivoted to starting to do wellness so you look at the
far column 743 000 i think 743 000 in 2015 that same story that i'm going to show you with a
thousand fewer customers is now doing one one million dollars and that doesn't even include
facility fees and the rest of the things that we take out of this ratio so when we look at that if
If you were to look to the right of this, this is that sheet continuing.
We track the average month, the lowest month we've had, the highest month we've had.
RPS stands for revenue per session.
So on your worksheet, there's a way to track revenue per session.
It's really, really simple, guys.
Take your revenue for the month and just divide it by the number of sessions.
Now remember, the more it concludes, how do we decide whether we like your decision-making?
With what?
With our money.
Right? If we don't like the decisions you're making, we stop spending. If we like the decisions you're making, we spend more. So when you look at the revenue per session, it was $11.98, $12.65, $12.35. Look at where it's at now. $18.01, $16.84. So we've gone in the same store from $11.98 every single time we service somebody to now making almost $17 every time somebody walks in the door.
So I know if we just see a hundred sessions that day, we're going to make $1,700 over the counter.
The next one that we look at is the average per square foot.
This is particularly important if you have multiple locations where you're looking to grow.
How do you know that the smaller store is a better store?
Likewise, everybody says, well, that's a 3,000 square foot store, so I'm just going to open up three small.
Is really a 3,000 square foot store the way to go?
If you look at your revenue per session, your revenue per square foot, your revenue per
equipment, you might come for different conclusions.
So you'll notice that this particular location, we're generating $327 a square foot.
We also know that our average piece of equipment will generate $43,940 a year.
Now, I will tell you something, and I don't say this because Herbalife is sitting here,
I would say it doesn't matter who's sitting here.
The one thing I will tell you about Nick and Elaine that I absolutely loved is when they first called me, I said, okay, here's the thing. I'll come without a filter. And Nick's like, what does that mean? I said, I get to say what I get. I mean, because I'm not going to lose my reputation for 60 minutes on stage.
You know, I've built 30 years of doing people's numbers, helping people.
So I may not tell you what you want to hear, but I will never fight you.
And that's all I ask of my team.
And Nick says, okay, we've got to do it.
Whatever you want to say, whether it's pro, con, whatever.
When I got invited to Charles' show in Columbia, I told Charles, you know,
some of the equipment is not working.
Mike, whatever helps the industry, that's what I want you to say.
But, Mike, you promised not to say anything about me.
Oh, no, I didn't say that.
I know, and the reason I say the revenue for equipment is, look, if you told me a piece
of equipment is $100,000, I just don't care.
I mean, I know, and you're going to say, well, that's because you didn't afford it.
I don't care, because I know I can pay for that equipment in three years.
Like, I'll use it for the next six years and throw it in the garbage can.
I don't care.
You see, if you gave me $100 and I gave you $500 back, would you care what I did?
To me, it's just an investment.
And so where your reluctance comes from is not knowing how long it's going to take you to make the money.
But if I told you, hey, you're going to make $43,000, $44,000 a year on that equipment.
In just three years, I'll have it paid off.
Would you do it?
You'd be crazy not to.
So that's why tracking these numbers becomes so important.
How can we make deliberate decisions about expensive equipment if we don't know how we're going to make the money back?
The number one obstacle I get when I do consulting, and they always ask the same question, is,
that's expensive equipment, how am I going to make my money back?
And they don't care about the dials in there or the UV or the nanometers that it takes.
people business people care about how do I get my money back and so that's where this metric goes
distinct customers if you have something and I I'm not trashing anybody else I just don't know
because I have something so that's all I know if you have something it will tell you how many
distinct customers you have just run the store statistics report under financial running for
the year and you will pay for new distinct customers so this particular store has 3374 people
that came in at least one time throughout this fiscal year so 3374 some people call them unique
some people call them distinct so uh 3374 those 3374 people can a total of 60 000 times so and
And that's also on that store statistics report.
So if you want to know how many times
your average customer goes in,
just take 3374 divided into the 60,000 and you get 16.10.
When the sessions, is that multiple sessions
in a day or do you use scripts?
How many things they can use in a day?
Or is that just 10 sessions?
That's, no matter what they use,
how many sessions did we see that day?
So if you used a tanning, you used red light.
So you will allow as many sessions as you can?
Yes.
Okay.
And so we might have three red lights, but we only allow one red light session, no?
The one thing I noticed, Mike, all these numbers going up, phenomenal.
Could you speculate, or maybe you know the exact answer, have a good understanding of
the one number that went down, which I think is positive for profitability, is distinct
customers.
So it fell over that time period.
Is that because tanners tanned less, but wellness at higher price went up?
Is that, do you have a reason?
100%.
As we started adding wellness, currently, so if we took the last four months, I think,
and it was, when were we in, when was it, Charles, in November?
September.
September, okay.
So I was doing some data harvesting for Rick.
Yeah, yeah.
So if we took that period, roughly 64% of our business is in the wellness sector.
Holy cow.
64%, and it's staying pretty static at that still, roughly 60%.
Now, let me tell you part of what's skewing that number a little bit,
so we don't say, well, let's avoid tanning.
We have more wellness modalities that lead to that.
So people can come in and they can do four wellness services,
but they can only do one tanning service.
Does that make sense to you guys?
So it's skewing the numbers a little bit. When we say 16%, yes, but that's because they can come in and they can do red light, they can do the saws, they can do the panels, they can do coal plows. That's four different wellness services, but they can only handle one set.
So while it sounds like it's really heavy on the wellness side, what's happened on the wellness side is we've gained more traction.
We've gained all the customers that you have, we do not agree, are really interested in wellness, right?
They're interested in health and beauty and how they look, how they feel. That's why they're coming to you.
So my question is, where do you think they're getting their wellness? They're going someplace else.
They're getting it from someone.
And so what we're doing is we're filling that need.
Please.
What would be your average, say if you're
building out a salon or your current salon,
that percentage of square foot is a true machine wellness
system?
So we are about 60-40 on the wellness side right now.
And that's just because there's so many wellness services
to offer.
What we found is, I think some of you in this room,
when we first got started in 93, you would basically do all entry-level beds
and then one big bed. Right? Remember those days Doug? And so now it's kind of
pivoted. Now it's all big beds and maybe one entry-level bed. So I think, personally, we're
starting to eliminate that mid-level section. Is it a little bit more
expensive to maybe add more elements and TLTs? Yes. But if you have an opportunity
opportunity to buy a membership that says you can use whatever you want, whatever you
want the best every time, and really think about it. The beauty of the element is it's
a 10-minute session. Your turn ratio is so much better. The experience is so much better.
I said this earlier. If you were to come into a California Sun, or if you were to come visit
us and we're walking through the stores, and my employees, if you ask them, what do
you sell and they say tanning, I literally will pull out a Glock and kill it. We do not
sell tanning. We don't sell wellness. We sell experience. And I'll preface it this way,
and this is really good for all of us to remember. Now, at California Sun, we walk every customer
to their room every single time. I do not care how busy we are. Some of our stores,
this store will see several hundred people a day. We have some stores that are seeing
five and six hundred people a day.
Every single person, every single time.
And here's why. You have
one chance to make that experience
perfect.
How many of us have ever been in a room
and the bed wouldn't start?
Hello? Hello?
Hello? You're yelling,
right? You've got your lotion on, you're
in a tan, damn bed wouldn't start.
What do you do? You know what's coming.
You take the towel, wipe all the lotion
off, you get dressed, you'll go up
Ryan, you're pissed. The girl says, I have to enter. Thanks, honey. You go back to your room. Now, did they get the tan they paid for? I would argue yes. You wanted a great tan. We gave you a great tan. But that's the wrong question, friend. The question we should ask is, will they ever get it?
Like, their food's not that good, but it's just a fun place to go.
And so, you know, we have to remember that a lot of people come to us,
they're influenced by the experience far more than they can get a great tan in here.
Nobody ever came out from one of our stores and said,
you know, I think I get a 7% better tan in here.
No, never, right?
And so what we're selling is that experience.
And so part of what we do is we really watch the analytics on
on where are we going with wellness equipment,
where are we going with tanning.
And so if we know that we're offering
an all-access membership,
and we know pretty much everybody who has that
is either going to want the top tier bed
or something pretty close to it,
then it starts making the decisions for us.
Make sense of what we hear here?
So we know our distinct customer revenue is $300.
A person at this store,
The average customer visits are going to be 16.1.
We saw 60,000 sessions, 69,000 receipts averaging $14.52.
Mike, what's the difference between a session and a receipt?
Because sometimes somebody might come in and they're over the counter.
They might buy three items, but they might go use four different services.
So sessions and receipts.
Sessions are how many people we saw go through the store.
Receipts are how many people purchased something.
So we do a lot of clothing as well, so we have people that will come in and they'll only buy apparel from us.
So the receipts get skewed a little bit, but what this starts doing is, remember,
the one basic principle I try to teach people is consumers talk to you with their wallet.
And we can see, you know, when we start looking at some of the blue things that happened,
we start looking at, okay, what did we do?
What store did we open?
What modality?
If your revenue per session or your distinct customer revenue, that DCR, if that starts
going down, what does that tell you?
Your customers don't like the decision you could make.
Otherwise, they would spend more.
Now it's interesting because if you look at the DCR, that second one at the top, as we added wellness equipment, look what happened. 181, 191, 181 again, 193, 195, 226, 248. The more wellness we added, the more people spent.
Now, here's the interesting thing.
Look at my distinct customers.
What are they doing?
They're going down.
My spending is going up.
That means we're getting more on a monthly basis.
People are staying longer on their membership.
Remember earlier when I talked, I said,
if you could get 1,000 people to spend $100 for a month,
that's $300,000.
If we got them to do it for two months, that's $600,000.
So how do we get them to stay?
When they say, you know, I just wanted to end my tanning membership.
A tanning membership is so important.
How many of you have people, and as much as you might tell them you have other different modalities,
maybe upgrade beds, they walk in, they're like, don't talk to me, I want a 10-minute tan.
And so they almost never hear about it.
So this is really where the big change has happened.
It's allowed us to capture more from each customer as they stay longer.
Now, this bottom part, the DCV, is just distinct customer visits.
We track that by month.
So if we look at every customer, we can see that they're tanning five times a month, five
times a month.
It's pretty static.
People aren't, you know, I said earlier, we get so afraid sometimes, well, if I priced
it off at that, people wouldn't come every day.
They're not going to come every day.
They're just not.
And so if we look at the top, the RPF stands for Revenue Per Session, so we're tracking
that on a monthly basis.
How did we do against last year?
So one of the things that we do when we give our team goals, how many of you give your
team monetary goals?
Like today we need to do 1,800.
Today we need to do 1,500.
The argument I would make there, friends, is this, that sometimes we're giving a goal
to a store, if you have a million dollar store and their goal is $4,000 or $5,000, they're
thinking that's more than I need them to do.
It's impossible.
See, the number's too big for them.
They're 19 years old and you want them to generate $5,000 today?
Can't do it.
It takes up their mind.
But if you say, tell you what, Rachel, could you do me a favor?
We had a great day last year and all we're looking for is $15.50 every time somebody
walks through the door. Now, we know a lot of lotion sells for $50. Can you give me $15.50?
Rachel's like, I can do that. See how we brought the number down? Well, $15.50. Now, if I hold
Rachel responsible for $4,000, and let's say last year we saw 300 people this day, and
let's say this year 100 people come through the door, and Rachel generated $200, or $2,000
I would argue she did a better job than we did last year, right?
We didn't generate as much revenue, but per person, she killed it.
So sometimes when we give a revenue number, that's completely dependent on us seeing the same amount of opportunities as last year.
But if we give a rate per session and you generate this amount of money per session, she's only looking.
If people don't come in, is she responsible for them? No.
We don't expect her to be spinning a sign out on the street corner saying, come on in.
That's our job.
Her job is just to capitalize on these people that cross the threshold.
So when we say $17 or $15, she says, I can do that.
I can relate to that.
I don't need $20 an hour.
I can get you $17 an hour for that reason.
And so that's one of the reasons we attract that revenue perception.
We also follow that.
Did it go up or down?
Did we take a manager who's a top performer and we move her to another store?
What if that really cost us?
We all have spas and, well, we all have people, I should say,
that are just hammered when it comes to sales, true?
Like you just know they're going to kill it.
Nobody can name you.
And so that's what we see a little bit of.
That's what happened here.
We had a girl who had been with me for a lot of years,
and when she left, boy, we felt it everywhere.
Just look at those numbers.
We were not able to compete the prior year.
Where is that track?
Look at Revenue Per Session 2025, and you'll see March was 1563 against 1573, 1559 against 1564.
It sounds like only a little bit, but $0.10 or $0.15 a session starts adding up when you're seeing 300 to 400 sessions a day.
and so what we look at there is the revenue per session company average so
you see that yellow line across that's what we averaged as a company and then
underneath is the difference of what this story is so they were underneath
the company average by 10 cents they were underneath company average so the
way that we do it is you're either underneath the company average or you're
underneath the year before so for instance if your store is always
always trending higher than the company average then i'm not going to hold you accountable the
company average that would mean we expect you to do less i'm going to hold you to the year before
so you'll see that this store on average is a dollar 62 a dollar two less on average well what
did that really cost us so we'll see on the next page where it calculates what that's costing us
the sessions will also track are we up or down sessions that's particularly important when we're
setting goals for the stores. So when we set our goals for the stores, we're looking, where are they trending? If they're trending 20% higher, we're going to trend that goal just a little bit more. But likewise, don't we as owners want them to hit their goal? If they hit their goal, it's a victory for them, right? It's a win. It's a sense of honor. So if they're trending lower or they're static, it helps me adjust that goal a little bit. Maybe that goal isn't going to be last year. Maybe that goal isn't going to be last year.
goal is just going to get to last year but if we can get to last year rather
than give you know we give them a goal too high halfway through the month
they're like we're never gonna make it and then they become defeated and then
what happens they check out right and who's the real loser when they check out
we so the whole trick here is to have members that keep our team engaged on a
realistic level and we have a standing policy with our team that if you come
company, as a spa director, and we can't justify our role for you, then we have the wrong
role. This is all that. So these numbers take our entire revenue, we divide it by sessions,
and so we break it down. Now we have a new metric for 26 where we're breaking it down
on the same customer, and I think Samantha put that in here. So revenue per customer,
so this is what we're making on average you can see for 2025 we averaged eighty
six dollars and eighty three cents per customer in January so you can see the
columns were very transparent and so you'll see in May through 75-71 and 77
the previous year so this will tell me what am I averaging per customer all in
every single month and again we're paying real close attention to whatever we do and then if we
see if it may uh this particular storm went down did we see that same trend across 20 other
locations if we did it's probably something we did sometimes it's just the location you're going
to have locations you know they're going to be at an ebb and flow is that the calendar year
Mike January to December yes it's interesting that the observation I have is your what we're
traditionally the busy tanning months or your lower dollar dollar numbers because your traffic
is higher but the price is lower for the tanning services versus wellness yeah that's correct yeah
so our what gets diluted there Doug is that our session count is so high in the spring and so we
don't have the time to spend you know at that point some of our stores were working four people
at a time right behind the counter and there were you know what we found is you
know customers as much as we may say we want to educate every customer how many
of you have customers that want to sit there and listen to you for 20 minutes
educate them about the advantages of UV right people are busy today they want to
be in they want to be out you've got maybe four minutes I said it earlier I
to finish that sentence but studies show that if we keep our presentation our pitch under four
minutes we have an 80 closure issue you want to hear the other side of that once it crosses four
minutes it goes to 15 people are checked out they've been taking too much time and so that's
why it's so important you ever been to a car lot the first they're on you instantly right they've
got a very limited exposure to get you engaged and they know it and so same thing if you've got
four minutes to complete this presentation um people ask me all the time why don't you do salon
tours number one it takes time number two we never start a policy that we cannot fulfill every single
time and if i take you on a tour and all the doors are closed i'm wasting your time i'm wasting my
I'm not saying spa tours are bad, for some of you they are a stellar experience.
For me, when you have a busy store, people, they came to us, they already decided they
want to tan.
They already decided they want wellness.
They just want to get in, they want to start using equipment.
And so we have a really nice laminated sheet that shows every piece of equipment, what
it does, how it works, and we keep them right at the counter showing them, rather than saying
And behind this door is a piece of equipment
I'll show you when we get back to the counter.
Behind this door is another piece of equipment
I'll show you.
This is our entry-level bed,
but we hope that's not the one you pick, right?
And so the experience is so much better and very important.
We are open to close very friendly.
Rachel, go ahead.
I have so many questions.
When you sit down with your sponsor
and you know these numbers
and you want to present them to her
and do your whole setting of her,
how does that work?
Is it once a month? Is it with all of them? Do individual meetings? How does that pay out to do the whole thing? Which ones do you recover?
understand this thing every way that they could possibly understand it.
I encourage questions, but if they can't explain it, and then we're also very deliberate on
how we roll it out to our squad directors because, let's face it, and I think we're
all smart enough to know, most people are just not mathematical people.
They're not numbers people.
And sometimes everybody says, all my squad directors, they start out this way.
I love numbers.
Give me numbers.
i love them i love them and then you start talking about what's going on they're lost right they they
all say they love numbers but too much data is too much data and so we focus if you remember those
columns i have highlighted we focus on two specific areas your overall revenue perception
because that's the immediate place we're going to see if we make a bad decision it's going to show
up there i guarantee if you make a bad decision in your stores it will show up on your revenue
perception and the other places are distinct customer value what are they spending with us
per month if they don't like what you're doing or they don't like equipment that you brought in
or maybe you got rid of something or you got rid of someone it's going to show up there and so we
focus on those two areas the rest of these numbers these are just distinct customers now here's an
interesting thing and you'll notice that it'll be on the next page so this is just emt funds
um i will say this i could spend a whole other hour talking about it or not because i don't
think i want to get out of here if you are not selling memberships we are a membership driven
society how many of you admitted in a car back in the day you would go to buy a car and they
And they would say, well, how much are you looking to spend?
True.
Now what do they ask us?
Or how much do you want in the month?
They're just going to put you on a membership.
And no matter what you want your monthly payment to be,
no matter what you want your monthly payment to be,
they will figure out how to make it, right?
Now, you might be paying on that car for the next 15 years,
but they'll make your monthly payment work out.
So we've become a membership-driven society.
Our cell phones, our car payments, our house payments,
our gym. They're all memberships. If you're not selling memberships every single time
something runs out, you have to resell a customer. Or what's worse is you're relying on your
staff who may or may not be in the mood for sales that day to make the sale. Memberships
just take all of that out of you. And it starts leveling out in your store. Every store that
that I have ever done a consulting for, ever,
has said that has been the one
smartest decision they've ever made.
Now, when I say memberships, here's the thing people do.
They say, well, I tried selling memberships,
but it didn't work.
Said, cough it up, come on, tell me what else you're selling.
I do sell minutes.
What else?
Weeks, months, days, kind of multi-months.
I give discounts on minutes.
So you're giving your customer every reason possible not to buy a membership from you.
We sell a single session, which is $40, for a membership.
We're in the membership business.
Do you know it's a fact 92% of people with a gym membership never go to the gym?
Absolute fact. 92%.
I'll be the first to raise my hand if I have a gym membership.
Thank God it's only $14 a month, right?
Planet Bits.
So, 92%.
What you're going to see here is roughly 40% of people with memberships in TANI don't even want to know.
40%.
When people shop you, friends, they shop price.
What keeps them paying you is value.
You will never get them to appreciate the value if they don't cross your threshold.
Price is going to get them over the threshold.
That's one of the reasons we always say we have services starting at just 99 cents.
Now when they're calling everybody else, who are they comparing it to?
How much is your tanning?
We have tanning for $59 a month.
Click.
How much is your tanning?
We have tanning for $39.
Click.
Nobody has tanning for 99 cents like they do.
We get them in.
Now we can show them what we have.
If you never have that opportunity, you're never going to get them.
And, in fact, I would say more often than not, it's us that keeps our competitors in business because we haven't thought about the strategy of how the consumer thinks.
We've thought about how we think.
And so one of the reasons that we track that average is to see when we make membership changes, is it going up or down?
What's happening there?
When we look at the memberships on hand, so here's the one that I was talking about earlier.
Look at the distinct customers in 2025.
So in December, we had 770 distinct customers.
See that number right there?
We have 1,296 memberships that are active that same month.
So we have 1,296 memberships active, and only 770 people came in to use them.
You see what I was talking about earlier?
So when the value outweighs the price, people will not cancel.
when people ask how did you get a story that was doing 400,000 to a million dollars this is how
this is how add tons of value and that's hard because value means what value means sometimes
we got to spend money we don't want to spend me too I mean I don't care whether they are in the
US or whether you're in Canada or whether you're in Europe spending tens of thousands of dollars
for a piece of equipment is not fun when i first got into the industry i remember i i bought my
biggest bet i think it was like 25 000 and i said god the day i spend more than 30 i'm out that's it
i will never spend 30 000. then i went to 40 then 50 then 60 then 70 right but what i learned along
the way it doesn't matter how much it costs it truly doesn't you got to get your head wrapped
factor on that. What matters is how much you make. Cost is irrelevant. If I told you you
could buy a car today...
Can you say that again, Mike?
What's that?
Can you say that again?
Yeah, for you.
Big capital letters.
Irrelevant.
Irrelevant is what I heard, Sally.
Yeah, yeah. No, I mean, I don't say that because Nick's here. I mean, I say that because
I'm you. I'm making the same decisions as all of you are. These are the same discussions
we have every single day.
you know this is this store is really not performing up to par we're about
ready to dump you know three hundred thousand dollars into this thing for
two thousand how do we get our money back how is that store trend if you
don't know all of these numbers about your store how will you ever know if
you're not make your money back like there's not you know we in in the big
world we call them bean counters you know there's people that are just
sitting there analyzing analytics why that's their job our job as business owners is to recognize are
we making smart decisions or bad decisions you only know that in the data the data doesn't tell
you their grandfather died for the 43rd time we've heard every excuse in the book right you showed up
late to work oh my mom's got cancer i thought your mom died oh no my other mom right i think we heard
all the excuses. Numbers remove all the emotion from it. But they do tell you stories. And
so the story we can see here is time and time again, regardless of how many distinct customers
we have, we have memberships that are not being used. Month after month after month.
So how is it that people are paying for something that they're not using? Because value outweighs
the price. Psychologists would tell you the hardest thing for people to get rid of is what? Does anybody know? Hardest thing for people to give up is a fitness membership. Why? Because when you walk into the gym, I just feel healthier walking around the gym. I don't even care if I lift a piece of bread. I just feel healthier being there.
You create endorphins, right? You feel good about yourself. You come home, and you're like, I went to the gym. I didn't work out, but I went to the gym. You feel good about yourself. It creates in you a sense of well-being.
Tanning does the same thing. It is very difficult when people experience tanning and how they feel afterwards, especially using wellness services, they don't want to give it up.
And so we also follow, I'm trying to get through this fastball, we also follow the distinct customer EFT average is our average going up or down.
So if you look at this store in December of 20, it was 41, then 51, then 59, then 60, 67, 69.
What does that tell us as a brand?
That even though we're raising the membership costs, our customers are embracing it.
Why?
Because if what they get is worth more than what they spend, it's a good tradeoff.
Would you not agree?
If I asked any of you right now, how many of you have $100,000 cash right now, right here?
You're like, I don't.
I said, that's too bad because I have a $3.2 million Bugatti parked out front.
First $100,000 takes it.
You would beg, borrow, or steal to come up with that $100,000.
Why?
Because the value so exceeds the price.
You'd be crazy enough to, even if you went and resold it, right?
That's how your customers have to feel about what you're giving them.
When that value, we have people, and we have it on video, where our customers, we spend a lot of time watching video with Kayla.
You guys have been out to visit us, right?
Customers literally say, you'd have to be crazy not to buy that.
I mean, they see everything they get.
I could get unlimited cryotherapy.
therapy, I'm spending $389 a month for eight sessions and you're going to give me unlimited
for $129? Yeah. When that value exceeds the price, it's not a big deal. And that's the
proof of it right there. So when I talk about the numbers being the evidence of our decision
making, we're tracking a lot of things, but it also helps us make really smart decisions.
Two questions. I'm sure you know. How, what is the average at your time?
The average in the industry is four months. Our current average is 11.
And then my second question is, do you have a lower level?
So that price is $29 a woman, $29.95 a month, and every membership has a $30 facility fee.
Now, what we do on our all-access is there's no one more than $90 a month.
So we remove that barrier, right?
So to the customer, the first thing that they say is, well, I'm paying almost the same price.
i might as well just go to the ambassador we have an 84 close ratio on the ambassador
84 of the times people buy the investors but you'll never get rid of it
correct no matter because we need um i don't know nick
it's like maybe maybe not it's 6.5 okay there we go okay thank you okay so yeah that was it
I love this quote. Assuming you can make progress without accurate data is like dreaming about a delicious meal and expecting to wake up full. It isn't going to happen. If you don't have accurate data about what you're doing and how you're doing it, you will never ever get it.
I honestly believe, I gave a presentation in Nashville one year, that every store is a million dollar spot waiting to happen.
And I truly believe that.
I truly, honestly believe it.
If you are working hard for $400,000, rethink your strategy.
This is the easiest industry to make good, profitable money.
And you're surrounded by a ton of people who are doing it.
But in order to get there, guys, we've got to know the numbers.
We've just got to know what we're doing.
Otherwise, we keep trying out things.
And who is the guinea pig when we use her?
Our customer.
And as customers yourself, do you like being guinea pigs for somebody's business model?
Not really.
I don't.
I want to know that the people I'm doing business with have proven concepts.
And that's what's going to help you grow.
Because they are 80% of your referral program.
They're going to tell other people about you, oh my gosh, the best value is, I'm going to
share something with you that I'll close with.
This is really probably the most interesting piece of data I'll give you.
One of my friends paid a firm, and they're a large chain, so I can't mention Rick's name.
One of my friends paid a company to do this research for them, and what they found is
is this, that when they asked a group of people
what the likelihood is that they would refer
friends, family, or others to the place
in which they TN, 70% said no way.
When they asked the same group of people
what's the chance that you would refer people
to the place where you go to get wellness
that you might also get a TN,
80% of them said yes they would.
Now think about that for a second.
When asked about the wellness spa you go to, you're right, right?
You get it.
You're like, yeah, I remember, right?
Nobody had a problem telling people where they get a tanning.
They also get a tan at this wellness place.
But when asked about wellness or tanning from your tanning salon, 70% said they would not refer someone.
It shows us a little bit of something that's discouraging, and that's this, that with the word tanning comes a stigma.
We may not like it. We may not agree with it. And I'm with you. I'm in your business. But clearly, wellness is a hot topic right now. And wellness and light live beautifully together. Beautifully.
The one problem is that as an industry, whether it's the U.S., whether it's Canada,
we have figured out the perfect way to dilute our own brand, to dilute our own industry.
We do that by equipment that is aged out, should have been retired long ago.
We do that by not spending the money where it's really necessary.
And I'm not an advocate.
If you go to Nick tomorrow and you buy a million dollars, I guarantee you,
I mean, I would love to say I'm going to make something.
I make nothing, and I don't want to make anything.
I don't want my presentation view to be off balance by what I make with Nick as a referral.
I'll never represent a lotion company.
I'll never represent a branding company or an equipment company.
What I will represent is California Sun.
What is in the best interest of that company, that's who I'm going to be looking for.
But I will tell you this, when people ask, how did you get the stores to produce that much?
It's because we have beautiful locations, great equipment, and we're surrounded by really intelligent people with accurate data.
And, you know, what I'll offer to you guys is this.
If you want more information, certainly contact Nick or Elaine.
They'll give you my number.
I only have one cell phone.
You're more than welcome to call it.
text me with your name and I promise I'll always text you back someday but
no I'm usually pretty quick I'll get right back to you and if you want the
spreadsheet I'll send it to you it's it is a little bit overwhelming at first
but as you start putting your data in you will be amazed you will be amazed
and I have a lot we currently do the data analytics for my goodness hundreds
of locations right now and just from owners that are like I still don't
understand but I just want to see am I making progress am I making right
decisions and some people are just not numbers people that's okay that's all
right better to hire somebody to give it to you than not to have it and so that's
what I would offer like numbers yes it's not the most exciting thing to talk
about but if you're a business owner and you aren't tracking your numbers we
we should fire ourselves.
Because it's the only smart way to do business.
Otherwise, you're guessing.
And guessing doesn't pay off in the long run.
So, you know, I want to thank you guys.
I know I ate into your dinner time.
I know I ate into your publicness.
Most of you are going home.
But thank you very much for all the time you've given me,
and for the hospitality you guys gave me being here.
So, thank you so much.
Mike, I will say that some of the best
lawn owners in Canada sit in this room.
They didn't go and do other things.
i was i was thinking the same thing right like no coincidence that this is the group still in here
taking notes and really built it and so thank you guys you guys are really the drivers of the
business in this industry so uh have a fun fantastic evening i will catch up with you
in night falls for those hinge night falls uh take care everyone be good you guys are going
When we did that last time, it was like a whole other thing.
Yeah, I know that.